[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks here we are we might be drunk
you know what it is you know where it is
the beard jews got the stomach flu so
sam is behind the bar uh we got a hard
liquor jew over here yes
exactly we've kicked it up a notch the
hard liquor [ __ ] i'm making i'm making
old pals today because we're all old
pals that's the name of the drink yeah
it's one part that's a parent's drink
yeah that's good stuff one part campari
one part dry vermouth and one part
whiskey this is i don't know who sent us
this but it looks kind of funky what is
it
is that is that britney spears on the
cover who is that zoe krabs who is matt
do we know who this is
no idea it's not [ __ ] beers that's all
we know all right this is perfect i
think right before i asked if she would
sleep with me
that's the face i should say ari shafir
is our guest thank you speaking of jews
we got the king jew you're an ex-rabbi
you've been israel you you've you killed
arafat i don't know i can't i was a fan
of this show when it was still named
[ __ ] i forget today
what was it called at the beginning what
was this this is sweet vermouth we
already have a problem
well you're about to make a new drink
yeah oh yeah that's a new drink this is
a new pal this is the boulevardier now
is what we're making that's fine both
great drinks both underrated
you know all these
we're a run-up beer we were drinking
we're selling a liquor soon hopefully
it's out by the time uh this is out and
you're out of the closet but what kind
of should also say i wrote it at all my
underground clubs yes and welcome to the
flannel panel by the way it looks like a
couple of lesbians in here really doing
it up the real portland crowd
exactly so yeah sam's uh hitting the
ones and twos he's going to make a
couple of libations
and then we'll all uh
was that a first name of the podcast i
remember i remember promoting it from a
waterfall in ecuador one more drink one
more drink one more there was a podcast
that had like six episodes of one more
drink so we're like i guess we shouldn't
do it yeah oh i don't even think they
were on anymore no you should have them
on one more drink was the spirit of the
show it was like the end of the night
when your friend is like i gotta go and
you're like one more that's the last
time i was at the said the seller with i
hadn't seen sam in forever and is it the
village underground with him and shane
we're all like oh yeah just busting
balls and you were like you're drinking
like no i gotta go and it really was
that like all right one more trick one
more we had an epic one me you you us
three at the
village underground bar upstairs
casamigos night and then i remember we
opened the door it was sun sunny yeah
it's
that one more like i'll get this round
oh well you got the last talking this
one and then damn and you see the cracks
of light coming in i know you know
you've done something yes you know
you've done new york right and then you
have to readjust your schedule like okay
i was supposed to do this at one i'll
sleep through that i'll move that at
eight to eight you know it's crazy
though because when you stay up all
night drinking and you see that morning
that you never see the brisk morning
it's like warmer than it is yeah and you
feel like you've accomplished something
and you're a winner instead of the
actuality which you're a huge loser for
drinking all night there's a guy
sweeping the rat pack
we all like it's the rapper picture it's
like no we're at the [ __ ] cellar yeah
it's not the race we're not in vegas
with sinatra the rat pack doesn't have
to be on for a podcast
that's a good point
but yeah you see the garbage men show up
you see the guys unlocking the
businesses and putting the metal gate up
and you're like if it was all if the
society was just us it would crumble
yeah
you guys exist and by that i mean
immigrants i was i was walking around
edinburgh uh and i early in the morning
and i saw some random guy was like
stocking up sainsbury's like a grocery
store yeah he was like oh he should be
recognized music what are you doing i'm
like just walking around like what are
you doing like i'm delivering you know
groceries to the stores what are you
doing up so early i'm like up so late
bro
oh they're coming in hot nice i hope
these are good thank you
guys you can get your we might be drunk
uh bottle of drinks glasses at home
right now they're pretty cool look at
these yeah we might
you got that right we've sold out
let's give it a shot here
that's pretty good
that's not the best that's nice it's
that campari it really does remind me of
my brunches at my parents house really
camparian orange
oh kampari shafir
i like it all right
all right mark is like a it's like a
video game where it just like a lines
upon
it's like planko through the pegs of
autism
blinko i can't do anything with numbers
and i think it all went to letters and
and words with me i have just calcula
wow is that the name of it yeah that's
what they call it sounds made up he's
the kind that cannot count jelly beans
that's exactly right we can tell you
what flavors there are yeah man this is
[ __ ] good this is good dude boulevard
we were going to do old pals
i'm glad that's the great thing about
alcohol you don't have one ingredient
you throw it in that's basically how
every drink was created i think you're
right we don't have this yeah we'll just
have this the only difference is sweet
vermouth to bitter vermouth
yeah wow yeah some guy was making a gin
martini didn't have gin he said [ __ ] it
we'll do vodka there you go there's a
drink interesting that's the history of
most drinks oh yeah you know french
fries were invented yeah fun fact
i love these little douchey queefy
stories but some french millionaire was
eating in a restaurant in france in
paris and he was like i want my potatoes
uh like fried more and they're like all
right so they fried him up and he was
like i want more i want him crispy and
oh it's how they made potato chips and
he's like i want him flatter and he was
just being a dick and the guy just kept
he was like all right [ __ ] this guy
we're making these flat as [ __ ] and hard
as [ __ ] he's gonna hate him and he loved
him and they started selling out damn
and then he tried the same thing with
oreos and they were like you're trash
you're garbage
have you had those yeah it's too much
like carnivals and [ __ ] yeah it is too
much it really is split it with somebody
unless you want to end up in a scooter
dude i get pissed i get really pissed a
lot on my for you page on instagram or
tick tock that's what always comes up is
the uh
it's like you're taking good food and
making it shittier i get the idea but
like i saw one the other day a guy has a
steak you maybe you could find this and
it's like baby belle cheese oh he puts
it in the middle
folds it dips it in flour deep fries it
and i'm like you just ruined a steak
yeah that's all you do yeah yeah i know
it never ends with these people you know
it's like the double down or whatever
the hell it uh kfc the the the bold of
the sadness bowl that pat and oswalt fit
but it's true we just have to keep going
you know we have to fry a twinkie it's
like when does it end it's like it's
already pretty [ __ ] good i know it's
made for like to be ready oreos are good
they're classic i like the vanilla
yeah i love the the chocolate gets too
much after a while i know one or two is
okay but i'd rather over do you ever get
the double or triple stuffs oh yeah do
you know they make all stuffs
what just the fillings jesus is
in a tube
shut up
[Laughter]
i might be as i said it doesn't sound
real i don't see it all right
what
a tube of just the middle is that just a
box yeah
that's like heroin
you want to cut it with a knife and go
it's pure
a cop puts a knife
oh you pieces of [ __ ] you're going down
hard
wow well it's amazing i mean isis sees
that and they go we got to go back and
bomb them again maybe we should change
your name to icing
but then everyone would like isis yeah i
know that's the problem i just need a
rebrand though these guys aren't bad
guys you had us miss i have that rapper
rodney i think liz gave it to me yeah i
think he had like seven copies classic
one of the best just the idea that he
tied a handkerchief around his neck is
hilarious oh my god
okay it looks all right you're right
yeah he just went to a thrift store for
that for the cover of that yeah
it's weird that his shirt is torn and
dirty i don't know what has that has to
do with rapping
we got to make you look gross and filthy
he knew so little about the rap world
that he's like it's this right it's just
gross people right he looks like a coal
miner for some reason he looks like he's
just like the gay guy in the ymca song
the village people yeah they're gay yeah
they won't show the ends of the boombox
still because they're holding up with
strings
i would go the other way with the
speaker a lot of those early rappers are
having serious hearing
problems the hearing aid yeah that's
that would be a bummer to see a rapper
with a hearing aid i really would be you
don't wanna you don't wanna live that
long yeah old rat like snoop dogg is
hanging out with martha stewart he's got
a cookbook it's weird to watch the you
know he used to be like a badass
murderer
he stayed badass do you see that kirby
enthusiasm video with him no oh
he makes a rap to the curb song what
what can we get it so cool it's just him
smoking weed and driving what yeah
driving around it's so cool i mean
almost like pause here you can [ __ ]
play it so he wrote lyrics
yeah yeah he raps in the song he wraps
along with it to the it's so cool you
gotta play music wait
minute dog
of
a
is this it yeah oh boy
you know i'm coming by the smell i'm
here when
you see the wheat smoke in the air party
people wave your hands
what are you what are you doing who
bought the internet what wi-fi
uh-oh
oh
[ __ ] how cool is he
[Music]
oh he scratched it a little
[Music]
whoa
wow
it's so [ __ ] red
this [ __ ] born
[Music]
ready this [ __ ] flow is
[Music]
like making anything funny like we see
some news story and we make a joke out
of it he hears a
[ __ ] song in the intro of a show of
an uncomfortable show
that's got something there dude he
should do it to every he should we
should get the cheers intro
where everybody knows
dude you hear snoop's rap on uh taxi
that was crazy
mary tyler moore so many
simpsons oh that's a good could be one
that could be a good one yeah damn yeah
snoop is [ __ ] amazing i've heard that
he's the coolest guy everyone said have
you met him
um yeah he used to smoke at the store a
lot oh wow
uh uh uh
steven glickman had a story where he was
like they were all like passing around
joints you know and blunts or whatever
and he was like i don't smoke anymore
it's been like years and years but it's
snoop dogg so you're gonna have to right
and then he was listening to his story
everyone talking and at some point
everyone's staring at him and he goes
like what's up he's staring at he goes
you've been [ __ ] bogarting the
the thing man you've been keep you're
smoking the whole thing you're like oh
[ __ ] what yeah and they go sorry i
haven't smoked in a few years or
whatever and then snoop goes oh what oh
you're gonna die
that's amazing that is like smoking with
snoop is kind of the equivalent of
drinking with hemingway yes it's kind of
that level of like you found the guy you
ever go to his bar in in key west
barcelona oh is it cool it's so cool and
there's no mention of him at all there's
no like plaque was like this was where
he drank you just know it's the end of
the bar nothing's changed it's there's
so much dust on the beer bottles all
over the world the only thing that
changes like in the mid 80s probably
they put a fan in yeah and that's about
it it's so cool you can get absent there
wow
by the way that just shows you
front and center that weed is better for
you than alcohol oh yeah you got snoop
still going and where the [ __ ] having
weight where's haven't we been i'm
waiting for that next morning shot
himself
yeah alcohol it does not end well it's
funny there was this uh there was this
poem by bukowski that it was basically
like it was for his another guy didn't
end well for him he made it through his
70s i think he made it further than he
should have because he had a woman at
the end he took care like took care of
him that's how you do it you become your
degenerate the first 65 years yeah then
at the end you just find a woman she's
like i'll clean up this mess right right
he had a poem it was basically like the
gist of it was you it's just like your
friend you drink way too much with and
you see each other once a year because
that's all both your bodies can handle
and you're both kind of just showing off
when you hang out together where you're
both just like like yeah this is what we
do but then the next day we're like [ __ ]
oh my god but that's how you view each
other as like your [ __ ] and it's kind
of there is some
i don't know there's some truth to that
like we don't relate to that you know
totally well it's also like when you see
a drinking friend you're like hey you
want to do this i know no one else is
around i was about to go home but
then you remember why you don't hang out
with that guy
yeah that's why we don't do it every
night there's some good ones a year
friends oh dude in new orleans the day
after thanksgiving or no thanksgiving
night all the old high school and
college friends would meet up at the bar
and it was like oh my god you're back
how you been i started a business i got
married i i killed my wife you go back
you go back to college where you're like
a drink yeah we can afford all the beers
we want i know you have money now that's
over 40 grand a year
and you're staying at your parents house
so you're like i need a [ __ ] drink oh
yeah amalgam of all this [ __ ] [ __ ]
and you just go blackout it is it is fun
as hell but then you you drink with
those high school friends and you and
you're like do you still drink like this
are you just doing it because you think
i still drink like this right you're
trying to please each other do i sell
sagalow the night after the seller party
yeah and uh he was like how long did you
stay i was like real quick in and out um
because we're pros and we've done it a
million it's a slop factor yeah i i
stayed too long you did i did i was that
guy i stayed till four
was behind the bar so she was hooking it
up and i live a block away so i was
laughing you know what what's the
difference i saw a waitress pass out um
face down they had to move the table
away and she starts like moan she's like
she's seriously hurt and then they gotta
get liz liz is comforting i was like yo
okay she's like uh they put it on her on
her stomach so she doesn't like [ __ ]
barf and drink it and then as soon as
she comes she just comes out she goes
hey ladies talking about me saying
got surly good for her oh it's great
damn those those parties are legendary
well the staff at the cellar can drink
like no other oh
it's crazy i mean that's why it's
i think that's why they hire them
yeah it's literally like you know the
knife on everything that's the process
can you handle this
but anyway staggered this he was like i
felt bad he hasn't drank in about a year
and he goes i felt bad being there i was
like yeah maybe i should because you
know that urge he didn't do a program or
anything just that urge like oh this is
why i drink it's for yeah
so the next day was conor brothers gonna
hang out like i can't i can't oh [ __ ]
everybody called out and he was like oh
this is why i don't drink yes yeah yeah
no i got out of there pretty quickly but
i do remember a few people drunkenly
eating that chicken like this is good
chicken i'm like yeah dude it's popeyes
of course they get it liz gets it
catered with popeye's chicken yeah
you're in a basement drunk eating
popeyes it's kind of great it's great
but you don't feel good the next day
louie cats pulled up a chair to that
table oh yeah pepper's like look at
these juice
i took a few of those home
but yeah there's also tattoos first of
all the seller party was two years
behind because of coving maybe more
because it's supposed to be in december
right right so they just totally blew it
out they had a craps table a roulette
table tattooed parlor who's getting i
saw you when you're like say who
somebody i saw that guy get two those
are fake tattoos no
oh my god i almost got one oh i thought
they were jokes let's see the swastika
but also it's like here you have one of
eight that's your options for forever
you can choose one of these eight i'm
like that's your [ __ ] let me think
about this for a while yeah trash people
but i guess you don't want to go rogue
like you give me something whatever you
think about it it's a tattoo yeah that
skank fest it makes sense because those
people have no futures
[Laughter]
good point no it was that was uh i
remember the last time we did one of
those i have pictures of
i've pictured with ari and you can just
see this glazed over look in our eyes i
remember playing beer pong was so great
i was on michelle wolfe was my partner
for beer pong and i remember we're going
against mo ammer who who's killing us
because he's leaning over the table he's
leaning he's encroaching on the israeli
territory
[Laughter]
michelle i remember an image of michelle
on his face like you piece of [ __ ]
cheater
and we're just wrecked and i'm like
we're literally like everyone's like oh
you guys were joking around like she's
not joking right michelle's competitive
i was pissed too michelle's coming i was
fuming i was like you [ __ ] cheater it
looked like it just looked like the
picture of why we can't come to terms
right we can't come together
but i'm hitting the shots like michelle
would not let it go no she would she was
really like it was that drunk glaze of
like you're a piece of [ __ ] oh yeah
cheating up beer pong this is secret
when her pennsylvania accent comes out
she's like now
don't say well who cares it's just beer
pong if you're willing to cheat at this
what aren't you well there you go
is there no honor in this world right
oh my god we need mo on here to defend
himself
you people picture her the wrong she's
trash
she's from like central protect hershey
when she ended her [ __ ] special with
with uh with um what's his name marilyn
manson marilyn manson
she said she wants to come on here we
got to get her on we got to get her on
you got to be careful yeah yeah i'll
bartend for that really oh yeah
i'll chime in here or there but i'll
just bartend wow i would put her on the
treadmill the whole time just let her
run and drink orthodox beard she lost
best newcomer in edinburgh to a guy who
did his whole hour on a treadmill no way
yeah is that why she's a runner now beat
him catch it up damn those christmas
parties were legends remember the
carolina you might not have been around
for that caroline oh i remember joe
listen i got in a near fist fight one
night
i don't remember i oh my god i don't
know what happened but we were both
hammered and i'm gonna blame this cause
he had to quit drinking but we're like
two inches from each other's face and
he's like you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and
i was like this must have been 2010 or
11. yeah i mean it was ugly wow what
what started it i don't remember i do
remember rich voss spin kicking jason
cantor and breaking his wrist
at
yeah he was just jason was just i think
drinking hard yeah trying to egg him on
he likes to poke the bear yeah also like
you got to know someone well enough to
ball bust and some people just go too
fast and like sure you don't know each
other also i want to [ __ ] your daughter
does not it's not a good ball bust yeah
it's not great is that your kid i want a
[ __ ] zing
i already was like wait what did you say
he was hammered yeah you know jason's a
good guy like if you know him like we
know him we know he's a good guy but
like yeah vos [ __ ] kicked him you
like horse kicked yeah boom yeah and
broke a rib yeah that sucks to get your
heart broken by a 60 year old jew i
heard he also tried to stay around after
that like that's cool
that's broken bro
there's no gas for that i think you have
a size six jordan emblem on your chest
like enter the dragon with this
the oldest man ever to wear air force
once i know right
dude i missed all not all you guys are
still going strong but some of the best
new york boozers yeah
soda lisp burgats
i caught
i think so yeah once his kids are in
college he's going to be a mess yeah i
think once he does all like the arenas
he'll be like i did it yeah i could take
a day off exactly he was fun nate was
always really fun and goes down and he
would go hard and and nate's such a
great guy too i know like you know i
yeah i missed i mean barcelona bar those
you know speaking of barcelona that was
i passed it the other day it's still
open it's weird when you walk by bars in
new york now where you're like a lot of
the ones you didn't think would make it
survive yeah and vice versa where you're
like oh thank god that's still just
because it's a new york staple there was
a bar on second half maybe we could give
this a goog there peters it was called
cheap shots oh it's great did you guys
ever go there of course that was like it
was cheap shots is it open or i think it
must be gone
10 shots 20 bucks things yeah it's like
i i was already to
making enough money like i said making
40 grand a year or more where i'm like i
don't have to do that yeah i went there
a lot
but do you remember
the continental was a big continental
the guy well the continental look it up
i wonder if you get a picture of this
guy
he's got the raiden hat on from mortal
kombat
he looks like the dude from mortal
kombat yes that's the sign let me see
him the continental was ten shot dude
did you get that guy walks that guy
walks his dog at my dog park yeah
there's a guy with a raiden hat on him
oh i can't believe he's alive
this is the the bar i think the melanie
joke is about nickel shot knight i think
we'll die
i think it's about this bar well it's a
continental yeah that's him that's him
that's it that's a guy that's a guy he's
got a great dog what are the odds what
are they you throw a hook at him and go
get over here
no he uh that dude uh yeah the raiden
hat that's like a i just see that you're
like that's [ __ ] that's the dude
that's him no sun poisoning
damn that's wild
ten dollars for five shots of anything
oh the prices yeah that's it ten bucks
five shots there it is it's such a
disaster yeah do you ever go to a
drinking night where they have like
dollar whatever blood lights or whatever
the brood in new orleans yes would you
ever go in there just go i'll have a um
jameson on the rocks like but that's
gonna be nine dollars
[Laughter]
look at this
i would love to have a what's that guy
bar rescue guy tapper john taffer i
would love to have him go in there and
be like this is [ __ ] we got to shut
the whole thing down because if the
lights came on there would just be vomit
and rats and jizz and all kinds of uh
and it was next to a mcdonald's it's
almost mandatory that a bar like that is
next to a mcdonald's yeah there we go
yeah no that was a classic that's off st
marks right yeah yeah yeah it's right on
st marks it's uh in third i believe yes
yes it's right by nyu the nyu trashy
area oh yeah you get some nice
sunglasses right out there too and a
pipe it's amazing a woman would ever
walk in there go to cheap shots matt
look up cheap shots nyc that was like
the alternative to holiday cocktail
lounge well we used to do comedy the
great bar holiday cocktail lounge was oh
my god we mark and i so
all right mark and i used to do this
show at holiday cocktail and our friend
eric i ran a show there and he would
book there would be more comics book
than audience members every week every
time he would run like 12 bad shows and
we're like eric book one good show yeah
don't make us keep showing up for four
drunk audience members it would be me
norman mackie list phil adrian yes more
comics on the show oh then oh every
bartender only loved mackie
literally he'd have the game on full
volume and then mackie would come on
he'd mute it to be like guys watch this
[ __ ] oh my god oh yeah that was a hell
gig those were rough days but you got
that drink ticket and it was like
there's so much to be able to get that
free drink and you really cannot afford
drinks i love this the best there's an
ice cold beer when you're broke you're
like this beer is six dollars yeah and i
got it from
well well liquor was still great you're
like what club is evan williams well
you're like that's the highest well yeah
i'll take it can i have one summer of
lol was great like that oh yeah
god bless louis for those gigs i mean i
remember i remember they tried to ban me
from lol which like ouch but uh i
remember because i i i don't know it's a
time square just tourist only
promised them chappelle
everybody else it was when people and
first of all you had to get an elevator
to go to this gig so people are going in
there they're like this looks like a
college
like classroom yeah
so we go in there they were basically
like studios yeah they were like a
little stage for like the scene oh man
did we bomb in there all of us but i
mean i remember lewis had my back there
was no that's too nice that wasn't it no
is that not it that's redone now similar
that's the new one that's where i used
to run a show when i was like that that
was formerly the sage theater but oh wow
but they moved it i was already banned
from them by then but lewis had my back
to his credit lewis always has
everybody's life
so what happened was and i'll put you in
a choke i think
every time he takes your match yeah i
think i said guys i need money and
they're like we'll pay you when we feel
like when we get to it and i was like i
have another set i gotta get paid and
they they made a whole thing about it
and they and then i said like all right
[ __ ] it i'm leaving and
and uh
lewis was like that's what real comics
do they need to get paid on time and all
the god that's a good guy yeah
that's i mean i told it before this is
the famous spot where bill burr was
doing the garden and he was like i need
to get up i want to just run my set a
little bit and they were like who are
you and he's like i'm doing another show
i just would love to get a guest set and
you don't have to pay me and they were
like
no we're not going to give you a spot
who the [ __ ] are you behind yeah
that's how much they love comedy yeah
they didn't give a [ __ ] and that's why
they drove lewis out of there because
they're like we can do it even cheaper
yeah you see people who
they had right before they broke right
before they became anything me you you
list uh veter who else was coming there
louis dave smith oh yeah they had good
good guys good good hangs there too
yeah no that that room was was rough i
mean dangerfield did the same thing to
chris rock apparently when
another club r.i.p danger feels but when
rock walked in there he was like oh can
i uh can i come in the guy goes um
like stopping him to get a cover charge
and then he goes
well he goes i i'm chris rock and and
the guy looks at the bartender would
like to be like should i let him in and
the bartender doesn't even turn around
and goes
[Music]
let him in that's all yeah like yeah he
can come in but like not sorry not like
oh my god oh my god damn oh it's still
around
apparently that dog's still doing it mad
dog old hair i like a lingard he's
underrated yeah he's a good guy he's a
good crew people like goddamn oh yeah
hooked up with her there's
yeah there you go
i was talking about good times no there
was a we had some good times i had some
great i did new year's there one night
what yeah it was ancient fields wow no
lol oh damn on the road
not a good place
tough spot tough spot lol san antonio
much better yeah
so funny those guys who don't know
anything i would try to get uh the big j
try to get me into um eastville
back then and the owner i want to say
his name but this happened to me too the
owner he was like hey man my buddy
already moved here i had a tv show at
the time
tv show send the tape yeah he goes uh he
goes i want to try to get in this guy
dub david off and ari should fear
they're both new here and he goes all
right i like this dove guy but who's
who's this already he's just a good
friend of mine isaac a comic i don't
know he goes and he goes does he think
he's better than me yeah and jay was
like what i mean yeah he is better than
you but like
what the [ __ ] are you talking what does
that mean what kind of answer is that
this guy lives a block from here yeah
come to your club for free yes same
thing i lived on 5th street the club's
on 4th street yeah i showed up with che
ted alexandro and soder and they were
like you gotta book this guy and he was
like i don't like him i tried to wreck
people there too i i worked there i ran
a show there when it first started but
then he was trying to underpay me on
weekends so i was like hey you know
respectfully i don't i'll work here when
you pay me the normal rate
and he and he actually did so i was like
it took like a month and he'll be like
all right you can get the norm over and
it's like god it's like that's the bare
minimum of you get the but he underpaid
michael che on new year's so
good guy to burn a bridge with
the future ahead of weekend update yeah
right or head writer of snl i know crazy
is it worth is it worth 60 bucks
is it worth that to be like oh i'll
never you could have been the next
comedy seller because
perfect part of town i mean it's now new
york comedy club yeah
judah would show up janine was always
there it was right there it's a
neighborhood place yeah yeah man no i
had a lot of a lot of fun nights there
uh the room itself is is electric on
weekend oh yeah holy [ __ ]
i'm there every wednesday at eight
your comedy club i just did your show
last week it's amazing there you go
what's the fourth stream well yeah we've
been selling it out it's hot hot soup no
no that's at the fat black this is on
wednesdays at new york just a show just
a show showcase o'clock man those those
old rooms like lol it really is
hilarious like man it's so easy to care
why do you not care it was never their
business model to care it was like this
is not all the people who drove out like
the canadian clubs who like never gave
like russell peters just a fair way you
got into this for for money i know do
finance why why are you doing you're
trying to do bad comedy to get rich but
that's what it is it's like you ever
passed by on the freeway like uh a a
building supply company like that's not
anybody's dream no they're just like
this
and so the same [ __ ] but they must go to
dinner parties or whatever and be like
what do you do oh i run a comedy club
what i love sebastian maniscalgar i love
bill burr i don't know
we get the lowest level people we milk
them for all their worth yeah exactly
we've got people who are probably never
gonna make it if they do make it we will
drive them away that's our model i feel
the same way with the industry like you
ever meet people on a meeting in a caa
or whatever the [ __ ] general meeting and
they're like oh i love uh prior
and you're like no you don't get out of
here
yeah dude i went to the wild west uh
comedy festival the nashville one yeah
and um that's vince vaughn does that
right no but he started
yeah but anyway i ran it's been two
years of covid not talking to any
industry or whatever and you see these
suits
at the hotel and you see them and you're
like i recognize your face i don't know
who you are i don't know if i'm supposed
to hate you or we had if we had a fake
relationship or actually you were
pleasant i don't remember anymore do we
have a bitter feud right you trying to
cut my legs out from underneath the san
antonio improv because i [ __ ] told
you a client that you can do better like
i don't know i don't know what shazam
but for the industry
you
you run peacocks yeah right
that's great
that's great they should have name tags
or something at least like i'm important
i'm worth talking to
i actually like
yeah
yeah i just do the the books you know
because they all come at you the same
way hey buddy how you doing right hey
buddy either way [ __ ] scoring me and
vito do that that's all we do on the way
go hey a buddy
there's something that just makes me
like i just shrink when i hear it it's
like a pocketbook full of them it's like
hey buddy hey champ hey sport hey big
dog there he is that's another one there
he is
you know how fake you're being or do you
just fake around other fakes that you're
like
alcohol doesn't help either because
they're they're even looser oh yeah
i know like they'll go up to shane
gillis like i thought the asian joke was
funny
get out of here
yeah they are uh
they those things are always you're like
how drunk am i gonna get with these
people i know i'm starting to really at
every festival like let's go out let's
go to another bar yeah get a crew and
get the [ __ ] out of here wait those are
[ __ ] idiots yeah they suck
your own guy's good and then every other
guy [ __ ] sucks no there's cool people
there for sure i mean but that but you
have to kind of weed through cool enough
yeah yeah not actually cool yeah
i know i just haven't i haven't done the
hang for i mean the only festival i've
done in forever was moon tower and i
think i just kind of did my own thing i
don't think i really hung yeah we always
there we all went for a walk a few moon
hours ago like let's not go to the after
party let's just go we'll smoke some
weed we'll go walk in the river
and norman was like uh it was like me
list the big j i forget who else a bunch
of people there we had a great time
norman's like let me go do one loop
around yeah
the next day goes oh it was two hours
and what a mistake
you're waiting for something that never
comes no you're right you're chasing
that dragon and then you guys had great
conversation you had cigars you had a
weed you had a joy a drink it was it's i
should have just done that
it's just like we keep thinking chasing
the dragon's a good term keep thinking
it might be this great valuable thing
it's not oh and the music is at 15.
we have to speak for this festival i
know we need our voice i'm putting my
foot down on loud music i hate it
everywhere yeah i mean unless i'm at a
concert where i'm ready for it i just
hate it i want to talk it should be a
separate room to go dance yes
brutal separate room with light jazz
but we can talk we want to talk i love a
party with like four rooms with four
different vibes oh
real dancing that's good
real [ __ ]
talking for the old lights
he's just reinventing segregation
every pool hall is like only classic
rock keep the black sound
no we uh
we no we i it sucks so there's people
who you like and haven't seen in years
i'm like oh [ __ ] matt brummer i'd love
to talk to matt broner and then you're
just like i can't because the music's up
here how are you it's a nightmare yeah
you gotta get through that time matt
brocker is the best i saw him in the
montreal uh
whatever room and i was like i had a
beer couldn't open it and then i saw
matt and he's like an alt comic so you
expected to be a queef but then you're
like oh but you're from portland like
mac can you pop this for me and he goes
uh-huh oh yeah it's like old portland
yeah he's just like he's just like a
like a hillbilly at heart he's like the
nicest dude yeah
yeah he's just so cool
um
yeah man those fasts take it at you i i
much i'm sorry we're gonna say oh no no
you go you go no i was just gonna say if
there were those four rooms i guarantee
that loud one would be empty
or there'd be psychos dancing yeah okay
it is some people's vibes dancing is fun
if you're a good dancer i'm a terrible
we're all bad dancers right terrible i
mean i'll i'll do it but i'm holding
molly really chance heavy molly
i went to a nightclub in berlin and it
was just like find drugs in the bathroom
and i was like okay
and this place was just i mean it was
like i said the only way you could i got
turned away once already then i came
back the next day it's friday midnight
to monday at noon and you can stay in as
long as you want first thing i saw was a
dude getting fisted oh fisted at the bar
ordering two drinks hopefully one for
the [ __ ] puppet master and just
[ __ ]
i mean that's double fisting yeah
do you do you way out of that room
oh
music do you
i mean dude there could be a video game
of ari's life i feel like and it would
be fun
sometimes you know i gotta get through
the china episode
south america i'm stuck in thailand
oh no i'm at the kobe boss
i can't beat him
um
yeah but it was just wild and you get
like i can't dance but it's all house
and techno depending on which floor
you're going to and then when you get
drugs you're like i can dance now yes
this is happening interesting it's
really just about letting go that's
literally all it is and i can't let go
you'll look like you're foolish but then
you see a guy with with socks and shoes
on sneakers and socks and then that's it
and just dancing with his [ __ ] dick
out having a good time fat dude and
you're like what am i worried about i
know what am i gonna look like that guy
is happier than us i know and he'll
probably get laid because girl's like
hey look he's free he's confident and
i'm there like what do i do with my own
yeah so good for him
yeah i don't know
maybe he's happy he's probably happier
he's happy that night i was dancing
non-stop and this dude gave me like a
bunch he gave me some molly gave me some
ketamine and it was just like you won't
do ketamine really i'm like well i mean
i'm here of course i would why wouldn't
i what are you talking about what is i
don't know anything about ketamine what
does that do it means like coke but like
chiller it's horse drank yeah it's just
chilly it gives you this
when you get enough it's it's it's a
better coke to me really i don't you
don't strike me as a coke guy no with
that honker
give it to me
before you get
yeah here are we just snorting at all
yeah like jesus it's like a game of
snake
[Laughter]
honker is the best word for nose
it's derogatory but in a way you can't
complain
i heard a great joke sorry the other day
some guy said something about israel uh
the best band for israel will be called
guns and noses because
i can't the setup would help it but it
was a great punchline what i mean yes
you snort ketamine um
i think then we were yes we were but i'm
dancing i'm just can't stop dancing the
guy who was like hooking me up here
there he was like
he was like you're not tired i'm like no
i'm having the time i mean it was 12 13
hours we left monday at noon we got out
of there
and like 13 hours it was fine but then
like the next day i did go to the
hospital
because my back was just really yeah i
we flew to norway the next day and i did
my show and then like had to like stay
an extra day in norway whoa
horse track no from dancing non-stop
horse trekking no issue
damn yeah i think the horse track would
help that though you would think it
would because if you're a horse you can
handle some a lot on your back the
jockey right good point that's my
thinking but you you uh
you dance so hard you [ __ ]
you hospitalize yourself yeah yeah that
is the old guy
uh the hospital visit pace yourself the
the charleston got me
yeah send him to the roomba unit
[Laughter]
wow man nor where the fly who are you
you're like bond you're flying all the
way it was a tour it was a european tour
but i was having i took like three days
off in between gigs to really try to
have some fun damn good for you man you
live i try see that's i did the bert
thing two weeks in europe with bird it
was copenhagen it was belgium it was
russia it was
uh amsterdam you you name it but he we
never took a break it was a different
city every night so i never saw a city
i never saw a dublin i never saw
we went to dublin
dublin yeah but uh all these you know we
went to manchester i was in i was out
you know and the secret is your jews
will tell you to do it differently your
agents i mean but like uh
but like you do thursday friday saturday
maybe sunday whatever and then you have
just the rest off until the next
thursday so you can either stay in the
city you're already in or go early to
the next city so like there's no reason
to stay in like um brussels it's just
boring it sucks so
go to berlin early yeah whatever you do
take the train and just like hang out
once a copenhagen is great it's great
what a [ __ ] fun is that your favorite
city it's up there it's the best weed in
europe maybe the world really really
yeah better than amsterdam see we gotta
we got like a bourdain here
a board with no kids that's right
yeah
no suicidal inducing girlfriend
yeah she seemed like someone was all
alone oh yeah [ __ ] he was the man dude
the man he was like who's cooler than
bourdain i saw a thing about bourdain
where
some guy was just like breaking down his
greatness on tick tock and it was like
so well put was like he just seemed to
have he was interested in everything he
treated a waffle house with the same
respect as like a five-star michelin
restaurant he was into so like he he was
never bored like that is being connected
to the world and he was undefinable so
he started his i just saw that i wasn't
that into him you know until he comes
out
and i was like he's got courage but like
but like afterwards i saw the
documentary and he goes from this chef
who writes chef books you know books are
great too
being a cookbook yeah and a really
interesting way of writing flowery way
of writing and then they were like why
don't we have some do some food all over
the country all over the world and he
was like hey as soon as i took that
first trip he's like
i'm done with that life
i just want to travel and like do stuff
and they're like can you have something
cool to eat while you're there he goes
yeah i can do that but he just became
this traveler good for him that was
almost unrelated to being a chef he's
like we'll meet we'll have some nice
food but like yeah it's about being in
vietnam it's about that that could have
been [ __ ] me and mark when you work
all this time and everyone's like he had
the dream job like he's got a family you
know he's got a kid he's got kids
he's
also i bet you like he was like oh man
he's so fun i bet you the second the
cameras were off he was just like oh i'm
[ __ ] tired oh no doubt about it i
mean it also is a lesson first of all
he's 60 dude i don't believe that i
think he was like camera's off like hey
let's go across town and [ __ ] get
into well he definitely had some some
demons he loved coke he loved booze
well it's weird when you when his whole
thing was like about sobriety and then
you just see him getting shit-faced on
episodes what do you mean this stuff was
about supporting he's a he's a
recovering heroin addict wow so it's a
lot of everything else yeah but he would
do he would drink on episodes you know
i'd be like damn he's drinking a lot for
you just think like first off he's
drinking a lot but for some how somehow
he was just still shredded i know
well he was a jiu jitsu guy yeah he got
legit he um he uh um what was i gonna
say fox score great another drink
yeah
did
just don't watch the end because you
know what's going to happen but at the
beginning because casino wins but i
still watch the whole thing i know but
joe pesci deserves what he got
his brother with a bed he's still
breathing that was dark as [ __ ] it was a
little tidy whitey's on peschi ah i
don't know if i could watch that now i
think i'd let it in now
on tv that was that would come on at
like noon on sunday yeah and they'd show
that scene but they they'd uh edit [ __ ]
they'd be like forget you crazy then
they show his limpless body he's still
breathing
dude i had a guy in my crowd in central
washington a long time ago and i was
talking about heroin and this guy was
like
i saw his like teeth like gone and i was
like and i was like um
you do heroin and he raised his glass
his bud light and he goes uh six years
sober
and i was like you're drinking a bud
light he goes you don't think there's a
difference between a heroin and a bud
light wow i was like yeah you're right i
got a point yeah let me just say one fun
fact about good phil i mean uh casino
okay
scorsese was getting so much [ __ ] from
the cr i mean guys martin scorsese he's
a director of thank you
he was getting so much [ __ ] from the uh
sensors because he was so violent and
they go
here's what we're going to do
we want to keep all the violence the gun
play the the explosions but
we want to keep all that in so we're
going to put a guy's head in a vice and
we'll just we'll just do that so they
cut that out and the rest will look like
you know nothing compares peaches and
creams
yeah so they put the head in the vice
guy and they go that's fine wow they
left it in so he got it all in what a
lesson push the line push the line dude
when i was doing this not happening
stuff we'd always like have that we're
like all right let's try something crazy
one crazy thing they can put their foot
down exactly and then they can come back
from there to where we wanted to be
right right what was one that was tough
to get on ari well it was a lot it was a
lot of like you had to protect the
people's like um demeanor so we had
somebody who was
who was like well any sort of like
liquor brand or or um one of my friends
took mushrooms and left our camping
thing and just was that a [ __ ]
mcdonald's like can't say mcdonald's
like but it it was mcdonald's yeah you
have to say this happened at a different
yeah they said del taco i'm like that's
not gonna fly that won't be the same
thing and you fight for it and then they
go okay and then ryan moran's always
like let me help you fight and then he'd
get it in right but that's ryan moran
who's a good dude he's the only one he
was the only one left at comedy center
he's the only one over there you count
on wow he's the only one left he's a
good person yeah but like there was one
where it was uh i don't want to say this
zeitgeist anymore but somebody used the
f word he goes they're going to call me
he's a gang member and he's his dad told
him to turn away from a fight and he
goes they're going to call me if you
know yeah
and they go you can't say that and it's
like yeah but that's the character he's
talking about himself at 16 years old
in gang life
yeah that's he's referring to that time
yeah you got to let him say it if he
wants to say he's a comment you can do
it in movies for some reason yeah and it
was this long fight and i think i might
have lost that one oh i think i might
have been like it can't happen there you
go and then other times it's weird it
didn't matter i had to fight for like a
liquor brand and they go you can use
evan williams if you want but that's it
and i was like fighting and fighting it
might have been saint germain or it
might have been must've been saint
germain yeah the whiskey of the guy
the guy okay and um and eventually i
think i told him like hey i'm gonna lost
it you have to say evan williams and
they were like you look no it's fine
like they didn't care at all it goes it
didn't matter if it was whatever jmo was
that and what's that about oh it's still
rhyme or reason of that [ __ ] yeah
let me just say this about uh uh
bourdain yeah yeah yeah going back sorry
first of all eric andre had the best bit
about uh bourdain he's like i love the
show i love bourdain but let's be honest
that guy must have had the worst
diarrhea on the planet
right when the camera's turned off just
like
you know it's a great bit and you know
he plays it up to 10.
but uh
bourdain somehow made a beer look so
good he was so cool he embodied cool i
found both spots because of him like he
really made you like he'd be having a
great time in some weird suburb of
detroit yeah like if he can do it
and the way he said it i already had
these thoughts from some other book
about travel but like what he's telling
is the lady who killed him it was like
no don't say the name of this place it's
like why because it's going to be a line
of american tourists you always do that
i've always told me don't say the name
don't say if it's a fun place do not say
the name eiffel tower the words out wait
what what is it are you don't say we're
talking and we're talking about this
cool bar yeah uh that does jazz on
thursdays in the west village
underground place
i will bleep the name of that on a
podcast why you don't want people
walking in your footsteps but don't you
want to help the bar what if they need
help
you can tell your friend oh check out
this place you'll ruin the vibe of it
you'll ruin the vibe of it that's true
that's a tourist spot but i'll tell
about joe's pizza
okay it's already out it's out there's
always a line it's fine and they move
that line god bless them yeah
with the line moves some places long
lines they take forever joe's pizza boom
goes right through boom yeah they are
good they're good so yeah you don't want
to ruin a place yeah you got a point you
got a good point what do you want a
[ __ ] bunch of fans showing up to get
but it's a good lesson though i mean
you'd watch that show and you go this
guy's got it made he's in [ __ ] thank
you he's in [ __ ] uh you know
madagascar drinking a drink out of a
coconut on the on a [ __ ] cliff
looking over the ocean yeah and then he
kills himself so it's like hey also
depression is not just you get the truth
no one's like
you get to travel
right depression is deeper than it's in
here than than booking cool flights
right travel could like it could help it
i'm telling everybody like exercise you
think yeah like exercise like sun
depression
he's traveling he's exercising these are
all the things they tell you to do
don't date a [ __ ] actress
that overcomes all the depression
antidotes maybe that's why weinstein
went to prison he got too many actresses
exactly that's what did it
did we had a waitress at this at the
stand who's also working at rock
rockwood rockwood yeah
and she goes he came in when he was on
like fail really and they were all like
what the [ __ ] and then they just had to
like keep going they were like hey can
we kick him out like the waitress was
like yeah tell the manager we want to
kick him out and he's like his money's
green just like anybody's wow
yeah but come on i don't know it's a
little tainted
it's it's crazy because you look at
weinstein he's so ugly he's like this
big oafy ogrey
just hideous man and he's got a good
personality
and he's rich and he did make some great
movies he did make something but he's so
he was able to look he's a great is like
the the definition of a great producer
all the tarantino stuff you all knew how
to cut fat too hunting you know uh yeah
i mean i think he just knew be like cut
this scene this doesn't add anything i
know i think he was that's why his
movies it's like robert evans you just
know it's gonna be a hit he is good or
like that guy who does every cbs show
laurie chuck laurie i know how he just
knows how to make but at the same time
you're like yeah it's a [ __ ]
obviously not a it's a monster a person
he was he had the idea to make kill
build two two things yeah because
there's too much good stuff you got to
double it up here well also i love
tarantino but you're insane if you're
like yeah one movie six hours
they'll sit through it i saw the french
version of it the con
festival version of it we saw it at one
of those the tarantino uh movie theaters
on the beverly whatever that one is on
beverly new beverly the new beverly he
bought it eventually back to back with
an intermission whoa it was great well
look damn if you're into it it's fun but
i'm just saying for like a mass audience
you know what i'm saying who has five
hours one and two are incredible
incredible incredible every one of his
movies are great yeah wow
what oh he's a [ __ ] i mean don't i
mean look i'm a fan
come on we might be drinking please
please
are you gonna are you gonna clip this up
quintin
you like stand-up comics we love you
this is a match made in heaven yes
quentin come on we might be drunk
start the hashtag book quentin on
there's only one eye in quentin
you're you're making two say quinton
quinton
no no don't put the second e it's the
first e coli
no that's not even his real name by the
way
i think it's ian isn't it yeah quentin
yeah you're saying quentin i feel like
we're splitting hairs
you're right cut all that out please
keep it
quincy
by the way i mean look i know everything
about the guy i'm a huge fan he uh he
worked at video archives and he started
a
little community about movie loving and
then he made uh my best friend's
birthday was his first movie on super
eight it's not great i got a tarantula
story please
very little involved with him i'm at uh
i'm at uh kimmel
went to see um morgan murphy was doing
stand-up i love murphy tarantino was the
first guest and she said hey do you want
to come to you know like oh i i mean i i
wrote my thesis in college on on pulp
fiction really yeah love tarantula what
was your thesis how everything was um
there was like a lot in there you're
like i thought the [ __ ] scene was a
thing of beauty and here's why
uh it was it was uh what's his name uh
uh travolta's character is always played
by a car or a race car of some kind so
he blows that guy's head off in a car
he's wearing when they have way before
he calls he's like we this girl's
overdosed you know the dealer oh he's
wearing a go uh speed racer shirt
he's about to call and there's a place
where uh bruce willis is walking uh in
the apart his own apartment he thinks
it's empty he's like nobody's here sweet
he starts walking and it pans down and
it shows a race car on a shelf it only
shows him from the waist down and that's
tarantino's way of saying he's in the
bathroom he's here right
now racecar guy is here right now i love
that kind of [ __ ] yeah it doesn't give
it away but giving it away if you're
really willing to attention to detail
man oh god anyway
that's bruce willis i'm gonna miss him
for movies man oh yeah he was bomb but
way to get out before you get sad
yeah you know
in 50 years he'll be gone regardless
and he'll still have that so many good
movies though and like
you know it's funny i saw him in my deli
once what took pictures with like
everybody you're just like oh he's just
like a nice guy greatest guy so um i
think he's got a picture of joe's pizza
anyway don barris is doing the warm-up
there and he's going around telling
prison stories he's like who's got a
prison story
and then he lacks eyes with me and like
from across because we're friends
friends we do the like weird like jew
and a at the end of the night at the
time
he locks so he comes over and he goes oh
sir pretending not to know me he's like
uh what do you got he goes no juice
stuff and then you know because it's
like corporate job
and i just said i just gave the plot of
hurricane i was like well i was a i was
in prison for a while
and um yeah and i i was there for a
while until this young young
african-american kid took up my case and
he proved my innocence
you could hear like murmurs like is that
what right right anyway it's in between
segments of tarantino's up there he had
done a tarantino trivia contest with a
tarantino expert lost to him
about himself wow
so then afterwards he's uh he's like
staring into the audience and i'm way
back and it looks like he's staring
right at me oh boy and i'm like turning
around i'm like is there a monitor
behind me or something he's like no and
then he does another segment and then
afterwards he's just [ __ ] staring at
me and i mean i'm like 20 rows up but
you sound like the guy at the strip club
like she likes me you know you start
thinking exactly i'm just being crazy
exactly no way
and so then uh in between segments he
calls barris over and then they're
looking up at me and i'm like what the
[ __ ] oh boy it was weird oh boy well he
does this go to the store a lot maybe he
saw you there before that okay yeah i
couldn't tell what it was and i was a
door guy back then
and uh
so then
barris comes over me comes up and he
goes i was like what's that he goes yeah
he was looking at you i'm like what
he goes he saw me messing with you but
he wanted to know if you were the
amazing racist
i tried to get to the green room after
the show just to i want to [ __ ]
deliver a pizza in a tarantino movie or
hold a [ __ ] that was my cue to go
over and butterfly you tried to give me
some time i missed my my [ __ ]
and they wouldn't let me go to the green
room and i was like
my podcast dick doesn't work man that
happens um dude that's
crazy tarantino
at least he was aware of me i was like
that's so i was it made my [ __ ] year
wow
that's amazing good for you man that
means he's aware quentin is aware of you
for a moment
he's casting you in the remake of dead
blanker storage that's uh
like jesus
if you ever do a movie about the
orthodox jewish community
your version of a serious man did you
see that movie no i wanted to the
brothers cone brothers yeah who who is
tarantino your favorite filmmaker of of
this generation yeah once that once i
did because so i was good i was like hey
can i do my research paper on tarantino
this film deck dr uh robert
dr coker and um and he goes yeah but you
got to watch it like 15 times you can't
just watch it once and you got to watch
his other movies too
and then it was weird because after like
seven or eight times watching it that's
when i started picking up on other stuff
wow i had to go to the library to watch
it and like wow that's when i was like
oh wait wait wait hold on he said i'm a
race car ready to explode what does that
mean yes and then they go back like oh
i'm starting to see more there's all
kind of apple cigarettes there's all
kinds of stuff you set up a world yeah
it's a whole world not to mention
tension and [ __ ] he just always does
he to me he's the embodiment of my
definition of art which is entertainment
with a message
so like you can just have a pretty
painting
but what's that are you saying anything
with it and then also like if you're
saying something but it's not fun
you know like a [ __ ] heady movie
you know where it's like this is it's
not entertaining but i get your message
but it's not entertaining me it's too
heavy-handed that's not my style of art
my style of art is you're saying
something and you're entertaining me the
whole way i'm pushing back here yeah me
too i i i like your movies because i
don't always think there's a message i
think they're [ __ ] awesome sure fast
and furious is great i wouldn't call it
art but is there a message and kill bill
is there a message like messaging what
about david tell it's just humor
entertainment funny joke joke joke
there's no message i think the message
is like connect with what you're good at
which is joke writing all right well so
the term message is
you're saying racism is bad it's just
right it's my version of what's the best
so what tells messages trim the fat yeah
these are just great jokes right he
leans more on the entertainment unless
here's my here's what i want you to take
home and think about tomorrow my
favorite i've said this before in the
pockets my favorite tarantino movie is
jackie brown because it's just a [ __ ]
great i love it it's just pinkerton
it's why it's just pinkerton his wow
wow well done
it is yeah not well
received commercially for some reason
but everybody later go dude it [ __ ]
rocked with it's one of my favorites
tarantino never fails to deliver an
awesome soundtrack as well yeah even
it's boring they were like hatefully
boring i'm like what i i guess but
you're still talking about it i gotta i
love david he's still talking about it
weeks later yeah
yeah his his not quote unquote like
weaker in films are better than pretty
much anything that year can i give you a
film recommendation i will tell you
nothing about it i love louie this last
night i told chelsea and the listeners
are going to love that you are bringing
a wreck here
this is not my official uh wmbd uh um um
recommendation
everything everywhere all at once i hear
it's incredible about it look up nothing
okay just go see it i just know what you
don't know
goonies and indiana jones too wait data
the asian kid
and michelle kills it she kills it
dude i heard nothing about it i just got
an invitation like you want to go like
sure whatever like it's about like don't
tell me we're going i've tried i steal
cable and i get all kinds of i get every
movie like everything still i'm still
stealing uh big jay's netflix password
i'm oh there's no stealing by the way
netflix dropped apparently did you hear
that but they wouldn't book you let's
talk about that
uh so i keep trying to walk but they
don't have it yet on my uh my case i'll
go again to the thing really
i would go maybe we'll do a little field
trip actually i'm here this weekend i'm
excited
but dude uh it's funny i i follow pat
and oswald on twitter and he's done like
eight tweets about this movie he's a big
film nerd he's like it's the greatest
movie i told louie last night and he was
like he's like uh american or foreign i
was like hey dude i don't want to tell
you anything about it i just want you to
watch it he goes i will that's a
recommendation i don't get i've you've
never recommended a movie to me yeah
okay
louie recommended the movie california
split to me so if you haven't seen that
movie that i give that a a high rec
because uh it's elliott gould and george
siegel as just degenerate degeneric
gamblers definitely the movie uncut gems
got a little inspiration from this movie
oh really it's a robert altman movie
robert underrated great one of the most
under i mean the player is as good a
movie shortcuts which what's your
shortcuts
you read the robert right mccarter book
about it and you see that you're like oh
they're wildly different yeah man that
scene with the waitress it's like
there's something so dark about them
just like trashing your wife who's the
waitress at the diner played greatly by
lily tomlin uh and tom waits as a
husband
where that redhead chick is naked like
from the waist down trying to argue
about how this guy never came inside her
so she didn't fully cheat whoa
what's her name
what movie is this shortcuts i've never
seen this oh it's ult man it's it's one
of schumer's favorite movies i'll watch
that this is that's it robert schumer
chuck schumer big movie fan uh no you
know uh yeah altman is one of the best
ever i read the book and studied it in
college and then harvard
had a class where we discussed carver's
very dark where we discussed the movies
i got an easy egg he's like what
that's what he's saying here about this
film
yeah by the film so wait did you know is
it errol morris who wrote rum punch uh
elmore leonard geez arrow morris is the
true crime guy okay who's amazing yes
who did thin blue line right right okay
elmore leonard elmore he wrote rum punch
which is based on jackie brown jackie
brown is based on that and he read the
script and quentin tarantino was too
scared to show him because he's like
your book is so good i don't want to
[ __ ] with it and he read the script he
said it's the best screenplay i've ever
written dude dude i'll say this too
about how cool elmore leonard apparently
was i knew one of the guys who wrote for
justify great guy chris provenzano wrote
like i want to say like 30 episodes of
that show i literally met him as a fan i
met him because my friend knew him and i
was like can i just tell him i'm a fan
and we end up just becoming buddies to
it but
justify is one of the best shows of all
time it's so underrated
yeah tarantino's gonna direct a few when
it's back
and
uh it's elmore leonard apparently said
like he's so humble you know he's he's
passed away now but he said like i never
could have written a show this good like
man the writers are and it's based on
his [ __ ] but how yeah but how cool is
that yeah it's based on firing the hole
but like it's cool when you're like you
guys are doing a great job how cool is
it the writer who's this [ __ ] icon is
like you guys have done better than i
ever because like generally you're
messing it up you're ruining my vision
right right but they really did kill it
like it's really a good [ __ ] show you
see worst woman in the world i loved it
i gotta watch it normally i'm gonna i'm
gonna watch it nba playoffs is a hard
time for me to watch movies i saw three
movies in a row i got a great streak
growing of like damn i saw licorice
pizza i liked it loved it people are
[ __ ] all over it people oh oh people
are [ __ ] on something
i mean honestly anything good in the
world
people i respect are [ __ ] ari and i
saw once upon a time in uh hollywood
together oh i love that movie that was
fun whiplash we had fun
we saw django dude
whiplash is [ __ ] awesome i know
people hate it every watching a flight i
was like i love it i love it it's great
it's over the top it's silly but it's
great liquor's pizza worst woman in the
world and then everything everywhere
worst person in the world i think it's
person i don't remember i don't see
gender i believe it but either way i
think it's personal but which in what
order are we uh i would go everything
everywhere all at once first and and i
don't want to overhype it but i want
everyone to see it so you read into that
however you want but it's not fun to see
it i hate sci-fi no no don't write off
genres
all right don't it's just just go see it
okay
and then and then worst person in the
world
and then licorice pizza but all just
like these are nailed movies these are
their moments in in in licorice pizza
the third best where i'm like it's such
a true moment that it's almost i get
choked up i start like tearing i can't
help it i love that nailed reality here
yeah we're such movie nerds on this
podcast like it will turn into a movie i
know i know there's something you do
with a drink right go what is what you
do when you drink oh yeah let me tell
you a pet peeve can i do my pet peeves
these [ __ ] dorks who come onto a
drinking podcast they don't drink
what the [ __ ] kind of [ __ ] is that it's
a drinking podcast ah you hear that they
come in
well appetite was because of us honestly
because we
we had to we had to backlog and we've
recorded with birth the day before oh
did he come on before liquor was
invented
drink
yeah gaff again i know you came on at
noon you're irish
now i i hear you but these people have
jobs and they're busy and we record at
noon a lot yeah so mark and i will
usually drink but we can't blame you if
you don't got trying to drink that's
disappointing i don't know if he boozes
he was the yeah
oh does he yeah but he was in the middle
of a press tour he probably had like 12
interviews that day yeah well loosen up
a little bit he's got a family what are
we going to like [ __ ] eggman to get
[ __ ] face
yes
you guys are two of the best drunks in
new york i don't know
he needs a drink
more you can't get a boner
we might be drunk is brought to you by
diss plate
displayed is a one of a kind metal
poster designed to capture your unique
passions they have millions of cool
designs available featuring gaming
movies comics anime with officially
licensed designed
designs from bethesda star wars netflix
and many more
it only takes 20 seconds to set up with
no power tools no damages no
frustrations and once you mount one you
can switch out a new one in a flash
wow
look at that folks holy hell
look at that metal is it upside down
it's upside down oops sorry everybody
there you go the triple lindy yes
uh and with everyone that you buy this
plate will plant a tree tell them how
samuel click the link on our description
to see some of our favorite disc plates
and get our special discount 20 to 23
percent off up to two displays or 34 off
three or more disc plates which will
automatically be applied to your cart
when you click the link or use code
drunk when you visit dishplate.com it's
an amazing deal and only available for a
limited time and i mean that's a classic
poster classic i love it it's light it's
fresh it feels good look i think it
comes with some minis too look at that
magnet there
super cool
thank you displate get on it get your
own thing
we might be drunk is sponsored by better
help online therapy relationships take
work a lot of us will drop anything to
go help someone we care about we'll go
out of our way to treat other people
well but how often do we give ourselves
the same treatment for me
working out or buying some new sneakers
is an investment in myself this month
better help online therapy wants to
remind you to take care of your most
important relationship the one you have
with yourself
we're in therapy we go to the same guy
it's necessary clean out the garbage
your head has all these horrible
thoughts
splicing your childhood traumatic
experiences you're a wreck you're a mess
you need therapy get out the garbage
whether it's hitting the gym making time
for a haircut or even trying therapy
you're your greatest asset so invest
time and effort into yourself like you
do for other people tell them how better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
maybe you got a weird boil on your face
or something you're weird you know you
don't want to see that you're all set
yep it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours give
it a try and see why over 2 million
people have used better help online
therapy we might be drunk is sponsored
by better help and listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
drunk that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-com
drunk
you got to do this it's therapy very
important take care of yourself it's
going to change your life you're here
what were we just talking about before
this uh oh true moments or whatever oh
you'd a peeve you said such a great one
that's my real thief there's a moment
where this kid is like trying to flirt
with his chick and just there's a mo
where he just reaches over and like
touches her finger it just brought me
back to like
high school and college of like getting
that just touch or when your knee
touches another
it's electric and who if you're a
well-known director right yeah well
thomas anderson anderson yeah he just
[ __ ] nailed that moment so hard are
you a big fan of his movies no but i
know i'm like i know this guy he hasn't
let me down i haven't seen all this [ __ ]
of course i'll go so i never saw the
master i know that oh it's fun
tarantino's top five movie boogie nights
that's tarantino's top five ever ever
that's an entertaining with it's a great
movie they're friends the way comics are
friends like uh tarantino loves paul
thomas no he's amazing
took a
[Music]
[Laughter]
she must have been great in bed oh yeah
must have been just amazing yeah yeah
you know when you're getting to that
good you're like this might ruin my life
i know it's like edging but for your
life
i love the idea of this trial you're
watching the trial i've been jerking off
doing it yeah but i like when he called
her a slippery [ __ ] he has to read the
text he said yeah it's like lenny bruce
were you almost just like he's like well
i didn't say it like that i didn't say
it like that
exactly i love the idea that chris brown
is watching this like
why are we going to try to knock this
out in the uh the bedroom you didn't
even punch her yeah like what do you
mean yeah you're great and now like
watching like wow i got off easy here
i bet i bet amber heard and joined up
[ __ ] again
i don't know i think i think if you're a
real artist like johnny depp is and you
want to live dangerously you're like
good point and all those friends do one
more for the road
dude i'm like i know but man she blows
me like i've never been blown before i
think so yeah she blows me like a
low-level actress trying to become
mid-level
[Laughter]
yeah i know aquaman was well acclaimed
but she wasn't that good this is what i
like about my lady is she'll be like
johnny depp you know he seems like a
nice guy she's on his side but she's
like the accent the outfit you're from
what's up
yeah i'm an actor and i
yes we will repeat this again you're not
sir ian mckellen no you're from the
[ __ ] south
get out he looks like he owns a jewelry
store or something you know he's got the
vest on the man bun if he was a nobody
and he showed up somebody said big j was
saying this like what if one of those
80s comics showed up to the club now
like emo phillips or something like that
we're like what are you doing dude why
are you talking that way if johnny
or like here's my thing
it wouldn't fly now if johnny depp
showed up as a young comic wearing a
[ __ ] bandana and seven scarfs you'd
be like [ __ ] i mean i can't use the f
word right now but like that's what
would happen well it's like that uh you
ever heard that demetri martin story
where mark maron's like
he sees him with a skateboard he's got a
long board and maren goes how old are
you and demetri goes i'm 28 he goes you
got two more years with that thing
which just encapsulates the whole 90s uh
comedy vibe that's the nicest marc maron
ever was there's someone in the 90s
that's as good as it got yeah that's
true yeah the now marion but like two
years too late for that
i hope for dimitrim once and he said he
uh he had a book with him at caroline's
it was like patrice norton all these
guys and they're like he's got a book
i don't know i love you where do you go
the subway what i want i want dimitri on
this podcast i would love to have
dimitri early comedy central i remember
watching that guy when i just started
going god damn he's funny he's
underrated he's a pure guy i love him
just all the jokes he's got a scroll of
tiny little writings dimitri
get the word out to dmitry martin we
want him on this podcast yes not as much
as tarantino but still we want ya
no we want dimitri for sure i mean he's
a great guy he's one of us like i hung
out with him in the green room he's just
talks like us he's normal i heard him i
heard about him they said when he had
that sketch show they were like he was
difficult
uh early when i started working
conversations like he was difficult he
always wanted things his way and then i
didn't get it till later i'm like oh no
no that means he didn't want to take
dumb notes from some suit exactly
because he's odd he's different he's
unusual so i'm sure they didn't get it
yeah they were calling me difficult for
the same things like why are you editing
this for so long i'm like because it's
some comic story what do you mean i want
to make sure it's good
yeah i bet they was just like no i don't
want to take your dumb note on this yeah
i mean you had a show
you sat with me and let me edit and give
you notes and then you edit it and then
you sent it to me to see if i liked it i
mean who does that yeah but you got to
make it good you got to respect the
count and then and then comedy center
those people be like you're being
difficult like no i'm just working hard
to make something good yeah yeah i keep
watching these i'm such a nerd i keep
watching these scorsese it was four
hours now i'm on the tarantino one that
one's four hours i'm two hours doc the
docs these youtube docs some fan makes
them and they're so dense and amazing
and
they all had problems they all had
struggles like isn't that cool cut this
out cut they think yeah he begged him to
cut the ear thing out of the uh
reservoir and they're like you gotta get
rid of that that's gonna ruin the movie
it's gonna ruin box office and he's like
i need it in when are these people
understand let the artist do what they
want that's we're gonna make good it's
not your vision it's his so even if your
thought is better this will make people
uncomfortable that's the point
i went into a two-year depression after
revolutionary road i mean it affected me
to where i was ready to kill myself i
never watched it i knew it would [ __ ] me
don't watch it but i'm like it's great
because of that don't [ __ ] nerf it
but
it can affect ticket sales and that's
what they're saying they're not saying
hey it's bad art it's bad whatever it's
like that's gonna hurt the sales
and they might be right but
then don't get into the business go go
do uh real estate you know i just
watched as uh the girl's gone wild doc
the guy joe francis it's on tnt dude
first i know
they kept running the ads for it during
the nba playoffs and i was like all
right [ __ ] it i'm gonna watch it
and it's literally like the like it's
it's first off it's called girls gun
wild expose which you're like all right
i got already exposed yeah yeah i get it
but then he's like you know he's like he
turns out he was a bad person you're
like you don't say
turns out the guy who tried to uh
exchange tits for a t-shirt wasn't a
wonderful human being teenage tits
teenage children yeah they were underage
well there's a great there's a sheriff
in it who's like an old man and uh
god damn i forgot where it was where the
sheriff is but he's like an old man he's
like he's like you come into my town
trying to barter titties
like you ain't gonna get out
that's the best part of docs is those
side weirdo characters you're like who
are you why are you trying to steal the
show
he's clearly like trying a little too
hard but it's pretty damn funny he's
like you don't ever disrespect women in
my town
and he's like that's all i do though
that's literally my job you're pretty
much telling me not to come to your town
oh he's i mean he's been accused of rape
domestic violence he's a terrible human
being terrible
but but like it's pretty fascinating i
mean like he's got so many celebrity
friends i looked at my life did go wild
it went wild it was the right point in
time for something like that perfect
moment but he was making like hundreds
of millions of dollars a year and then
all of a sudden the internet shows up
and people ain't spending 29.99 on
[ __ ] dvds of tits now we're getting
doubles exactly
yeah come on but i heard the lawyer she
said you know this is like it's
interesting in porn they call the money
shot you know the andy and we all know
what the money shot is but she's like in
this it was the loss of innocence it was
like when the woman like and you're like
oh [ __ ] this is pretty dark man wow yeah
you want to see a normal girl take a tit
so you don't want to see a porn star you
want to see someone exactly good
i mean mardi gras had that all the time
like take a chance i'm like no then like
throw beads out like oh my gosh yeah
yeah
as well it's true i saw a lot of tits as
a kid yeah
i saw a lot of dicks too yeah it was
dicks at mardi gras that was just
catholic school but yeah the the
innocence thing is very interesting
that's so true
uh because that's really why you bought
it was it the realness jimmy kimmel
always had that funny story back before
he was a tv what do you call it a late
night guy he said uh the best strip club
would be you go in there's a waitress
and like a hoodie and jeans you know
doing her thing and then you she's got
glasses on you get to know her a little
bit and then she would go up and get
naked that would be a way better strip
club than just like the heels and the
fishnets and the yeah
and she was like i shouldn't yeah
yeah
i was that always resonated i was like
that this guy knows there's a casualness
to the nudity of strip clubs it's
unenticing to me yeah this becomes
unspecial yeah that's but it's like i
want to like i don't love it
it's just too casual and there's too
many dudes around i don't like i'm not a
strip club guy
i'm not either hooker all right
for norman's bachelor party we're just
watching movies
the stripper one with the chick from
save by the bell
oh
that movie is pretty funny dude have you
ever seen the family guy thing of robert
loggia
no dude pull that up it's so [ __ ]
good it's so dumb family guy covered
everything they covered
everything it's so this is one of the
dumbest things i've ever seen but it's
like he [ __ ] played along too which
is like why you got to love him was he
in it he's in one of them i don't know
if he's in all of them but dude
first off crush feats lamanna and the
soprano oh yeah amazing
here we go
can you spell that for me certainly
that's robert loggia r as in robin
oh as in oh my god it's robert
b as in by god that's robber blanca
e as in everybody loves robert
r as in robert
t is in tim look over there
though he was in one before he died i
bet that's him no that's him i bet it's
him it's gotta be him
got it they're like i bet family
governor is like this could work for
seven different people yeah so call
robert first tell them hey there won't
be a negotiation because we have [ __ ]
um i don't know whoever yeah is next he
loves the family wow look at this oh
that's great damn he was great he's in a
lot of movies he died he's got to be
dead he died a few years ago he was
awesome thank god
he loves death
no dude he was the [ __ ] best
wow see i saw when i was a new comic
like just moved to new york i was
bombing a lot i was getting yelled at
for being whatever offensive and i saw
seth macfarlane on some panel on some
show and he was like i get bags and bags
of hate mail like i should die uh cancel
the show blah blah blah and i remember
being like oh this guy gets hate mail
right i'm i'm fine and no one's gonna
remember that anything there is i
remember him being funny anything big
anything i'm so sick if it's almost so
hacky when you're like there's a
backlash to so and so i was like of
course it doesn't matter
yeah every single thing that's out
because everyone's like way in way in
and everyone's like i don't want to
weigh in the way everybody's weighing in
right so i was like what do you think of
that lighter is that an extension of the
lighter oh cool cool cool it's like well
some people are saying it doesn't fit in
your pocket as much a lot of people are
saying it doesn't fit in your pocket are
you right right you just folks they have
to focus on the negatives any stand-up
writer any comedy writer not i'm not
talking about like writing actual
stand-up like writing about stand-up
they're only paid
to [ __ ] on things yeah they're not paid
to be like this guy was a great charity
i saw the newest thing now is a podcast
critic john smith i'm like podcast
we're sitting around talking about
[ __ ] on microphones while drinking
and you know it's not going to be a real
critique or like i think it's like 20
minutes to get started this week yeah
but critics are only you have to look at
this wait they're only going to get if
they [ __ ] on you you're only going to
get more less you're getting bigger
you're not losing listeners out of that
yeah i guess so but i'm still a
sensitive queef where i'm like yeah who
gives a [ __ ]
[ __ ] let them complain let them
complain they bow at our feet we're free
and they're not
[Laughter]
he says that in the longest blue socks
i've ever seen look how free i am
they look comfy i love a comfy sock
they're bumble they're from emily at the
stand i got a couple i got comfy socks
on myself i love it i gave her tickets
to um i think outside lands or something
i bought her two tickets because she saw
the who there
yeah who the who wow
she took all these death threats after
one of one one of my many [ __ ]
e-ragers i think the kobe won but it
might be a different one and she's
people just kept calling she's answering
the phone i'll [ __ ] kill you i'm
gonna bomb that place and i'm like emily
i'm really sorry i had to do that
take your two tickets to a [ __ ]
minute there you go good man wait
speaking of things you like what about a
p i gotta pee hit me fast so i my
ability required that we get locks
changed for whatever reason i don't know
why then you do it building well they
did it they they paid for it okay but
i i the guy comes by and you know comes
by like an hour and a half late whatever
i mean i'm annoyed because i have to
come here but it's a little times by
late and then and then uh i go hey man
i'm sorry you were late i got to hop in
the shower and he goes enjoy
what well guess what now i won't oh yeah
now i have to what am i going to enjoy
now i'm going to be in the shower like
yes
yes
this is an amazing shower thank you you
can't jerk off with a locksmith
yeah the worst guy enjoy a locksmith
he's in your holly crack he can get in
your opponent he was cracking me up but
i mean uh
enjoys he enjoys ruff
first i would never think of even
enjoying the show you just shower it's
the thing you gotta do
there's a couple things you can't say
enjoyed too yeah and and showering is
one so it's like something's like i'm
already gonna do this regardless i
wasn't gonna not enjoy and now i will
yeah you know i just saw speed for the
first time one of the best a night or
two ago great movie and he's going into
did you like it
yeah it was great it's also on twitter
it might be the
dumb it might be the best action movie
ever it was great but he loses his
partner
i don't know 40 minutes ago and then
he's falling in love like everything's
gonna be great yeah like your partner
just died i know but tell me a better
action movie it's great
it's non-stop but also this is amazing
where he's going into the house or going
into under the car or something like
that and i forget who's either jeff
daniel says to him or he says jeffrey
knows be careful and it's like
i mean i'm going to disarm a bomb i was
already going to be as careful yeah
right but it wasn't careful enough
thanks for telling me
yeah enjoy [ __ ] that guy enjoy it no i
mean it was kind of funny i don't know
he does
[Laughter]
pop quiz hot shot oh dude
come on yeah that's what i'm saying
speed is [ __ ] awesome you got a great
villain
fires through the roof ten times it
can't hit anybody yeah right right he's
like i'll just go fight this guy on top
of a train
so it makes you realize how cool keanu's
been forever
young in it and started what's her name
sandra bullock
wildcat yes yeah she was great that was
that was a great that's a great
blockbuster action
i'm seeing it because it's like 30 years
ago so i'm seeing it with now looking
back and everything's so dumb and it's
like sam wait for the bus buster and i'm
like what do you get the bus exactly the
same time every day yeah there's more
than one bus driver in this route so if
you're 10 minutes late you what do you
mean how do you know your bus driver
right well it's a different time
different the 90s
i will say it feels like we're making a
shift to foreign films
because there's less annoying [ __ ]
there's less like like the worst person
in the world no spoiler it's just a
bunch of white people well in norwegian
they're trying to get on jay-z for like
they're like oh your factory is only way
people and he's like it's in norway
there's no lie in the movie no no this
is really actual life that came after
him because like look at you taking a
picture with all your employees at this
factory and he goes it's my european
norway wow they're about to choose from
they're giving a black guy [ __ ] about
white worker i mean
but it's like a looking glass exactly
but like uh yeah foreign films because
if you make it like a 70s cop movie here
you couldn't do it with the level of
racism they actually had they have right
you couldn't show it real
right they'd have to be completely
independent and then even if you tried
to sell it even though when they remade
the sopranos movie i thought the racism
felt so forced i agree
like you know uh like in the sopranos
the racism felt like real real yes and
then you're watching it in the many
sense in newark and you're like how is
this earlier and it feels more buttoned
up yeah
how was this in the 70s and so you're
like wait what one of the first ones i
saw was the comedy store show whatever
it's called so i'm dying up here yes and
it was like right during me too between
season like two and season three and
they started making all these women like
really powerful characters in like the
late 70s yeah oh yeah no well they did
that in the errands
uh i love lucy movie
uh ricardo's oh it's awful i didn't
watch there's this literally one of the
first scenes as a female writer tells
the show the
jess oppenheimer whatever his name is
the show runner like like shut up and
it's like yeah that's that's what
happened in the showroom you were
getting arrested that's what happened in
the 50s right back in my hand i mean
it's like i get that it's like all about
empowerment and stuff but like you're
either making an accurate movie or
you're not are you making revisionists
make it in the future yeah yeah and also
right lucille ball killed it was amazing
she changed the one she was the the the
biggest
golden star yeah star on the planet with
this tv show about her like that's
enough she made it that's the movie yeah
that's the powerful female character
yeah exactly just doing it
which is also what a lot of feminism is
and what a lot of like race like like
any latino comic when i started was like
you own your own car you're a [ __ ]
superstar you know you don't have to be
empowering or anything like that like
paul rodriguez and mencia and like and
like uh soda really percent and see you
and see what car you were driving he
would take it
but it was just like you're doing it so
that's your empowerment feminism it's
like you're doing it that is feminism
that's it and then it's weird that a lot
of people you know it's like whitey
sucks but like they'll
they'll uh act like the white guy you
know they're like i want to be the ceo
and wear the the suit and everything
you're like i thought you hated that
yeah we invented that well i don't get i
don't get yeah i mean
it was just a different time just make
it you don't have to make it through
today's lens
roseanne was like yeah i'm going to be a
housewife great no real maybe i'll get a
job at a [ __ ] diner or fact like
these were my midwestern possibilities
for that show felt very honest to people
i think that's why i was opening up
motorcycle repair shops
same [ __ ] it was the same time i was
like well this i'm a shoe salesman i
mean i don't have everything every time
he walked in he would go uh a fat lady
came into the shoe store today applause
break yeah that was an applause break i
know i know let's rock because it was
like [ __ ] like my life sucks and
people like they they found that funny
yes he was the lowest scum of the earth
so when he had a win you you went nuts
yeah his wife was just trying to get him
to [ __ ] her i know and she was way too
hot for him way too long and he was
still like uh
yeah
and all he did was reminisce about his
four touchdowns in one game it was like
right okay we can all relate to this i
mean we could all relate to be like
those were the days i heard john hughes
was doing a movie before he died he's
writing it about all his characters from
his other movies where they are now
oh and the one that i remember the guy
the nerd from 16 candles was like some
ceo somewhere but the best was ferris
bueller with some dumb mid-level manager
wow he's still talking about that one
day he had where he took off
and he went on the parade and he's
almost saw his dad hilarious he's still
talking about that was his one moment
well that's interesting because that's
sherman's favorite by the way love that
yeah i love that movie it was great but
uh
you say the the american children thing
is it's interesting point because it was
like it was a very like
blow brow show but it was kind of
sophisticated in the same way of all in
the family whereas like you got this
protagonist he's a loser he's a shoe
salesman he's a balding piece of [ __ ]
whatever flawed hates his wife
but
you knew that and so everything else was
it was all punching up because he was
the loser his son's a loser yeah his
daughter's a [ __ ] yeah i mean this is
like he has not once at all his last
good day was [ __ ] senior year of high
school exactly happened to find four
holes in the [ __ ] line yeah
yes but it's the same with archie bunker
like he he was racist he was sexist he's
doing the best he could as a raised
racist yes he had a [ __ ] dry cleaner
friend and he was the punchline that's a
[ __ ] guy
but you couldn't do that now because
they'd go well he's a racist you're like
i know but that's the that's the joke he
sucks i know the joke is that but people
are too literal yeah but now if that was
the show that would be the whole show
that would be the whole show like this
guy's racist instead of it being a small
part of like i mean we've talked about
this before but as good as it gets like
yeah we watch it oh yeah i forgot
nicholson just is like [ __ ] on jesus
oh
he's like he's like look at these noses
like you know and you're like oh [ __ ] i
forgot if they remade this it was just
he was just shitty in every way that was
the point of nicholson's character right
yeah you're right the women one of the
greatest just right
how do you write women so well i think
of a man and i take away reason and
accountability
it's amazing i mean it's the best it won
best picture for christ's sakes did it
yeah i think titanic won that yeah he
won though he won maybe best what are
the ones what are the ones that should
have won and that makes you angry that
it didn't
la confidential's up there
lost to what uh i think shakespeare in
love
but pulp fiction i think forest gump is
overrated fargo win best picture man uh
here's one in the bedroom one of my
favorite movies that's a great marissa
i don't know
dark lost to uh beautiful mind and
that's something i threw a drink down at
because i was so mad at it oh okay it
did win best picture oh good that's a
win fargo is a fargo's francis mcdormand
killed it
yeah wait wait wait did we get a we got
a peeve yeah i got to do a piece yeah
yeah yeah you did a peeve yeah you
yelled to peeve sorry i was working i
like it i was worked up i like that
listeners are gonna like that one too
the listeners should like it
cause [ __ ] these are good ass drinks
this is my last drink for a while and
the reason i'm doing this because i'm
like oh obviously i'm gonna drink on we
might be drunk hell yeah obviously i'm
drinking but these are good ass
boulevardiers dude very good i planned
on old bridge but we called an audible
and these kind of worked out pretty damn
well i like the idea of like we're going
for a drink let's just do it like when
we had godfathers at my house and it was
like we're going for one drink and we're
[ __ ] doing it that was listen to that
that was great another grandfather
another what is it if you ever listen to
that episode me and norman did always
pod skeptic tank uh that was fun as hell
it's over 100k i checked really yeah
it's killing it
yeah was it best picture
which one matt it's good skeptic tank no
it was titanic dude that was good 198.
you can't beat titanic
that i'll understand actor best actress
yeah and uh it was
james albrook's [ __ ] rules oh yeah
he's great simpsons [ __ ] him
well nicholson won
oh ellie confidential was that that was
a stacked year right robin williams
[Music]
wait what one best movie titanic no best
film editing no i know we don't have
best picture up here but i can't we all
remember titanic one but i mean did when
the sounder links
boogie l.a confidential good will
hunting wow that's a stacked movie you
did movies suck now or american movies
suck i should say other people have
caught up we've we restrained ours too
much yes it's like taxi drivers
like well now he's uber
here's the norwegian film called [ __ ]
worst woman in the world and taxi driver
great person will smith was at that
oscars too he didn't slap anybody didn't
slap anybody
damn what else men in black that was a
fun movie men and black's great oh yeah
good the first one's incredible dude so
he's banned from the oscars for ten
years what if he wins another one in
like eight years when everyone he could
he could win he could he gets he's gonna
accept this from his house or they're
gonna be like just come you're one i
don't think he's gonna win one
i think what he did was horrible i think
what roman polanski did was worse
yeah a bit
but uh both banned i think what he did
was [ __ ] there's no way one of those
12 year old girls run with clancy like
shuffle the goal what i just got raped
by roman polanski dude another huge
wreck this is the greatest night oscars
in the world check out the book the big
goodbye by sam lawson it's all about
polanski and uh nicholson and the making
of chinatown it's one of the best movie
books ever check it out the big goodbye
pull up pictures i love that behind the
scenes it's phenomenal it make it'll
make you think nicholson's pretty
[ __ ] cool too he was great in um
easy right look at that cover
easy riders [ __ ] that that was i
thought i was a pin that movie for me
they didn't want him in it either
apparently really yeah i think dennis
hopper wanted someone else and then he
was like no he killed it like later he's
like yeah he killed it yeah because he
was still a newish guy then yeah he was
great as a straight edge guy who had to
be killed because he was the the barrier
between the spoilers and the right
yes
all right here's my peeve yes sorry i
got two two little ones that maybe will
add up to a big one okay one
the guy who puts blacks
the guy
uh
there's like mult like limited chairs in
a room and the guy who puts his stuff on
a chair takes up a whole chair with his
bag his jacket he's not allowed not
allowed i don't know who opened for
norman last weekend but we all know this
was in a green room that was how dare
you want your space in a tight room
what's wrong
put your bag on the floor or put it on
your lap on your floor absolutely not
you can't do it in a movie theater this
is someone's seat i'll take it a step
further subway oh
the bag on the seat subway person
deserves to be shot in the face dude
how come the subway shooter should just
be going after that person yes yes
that's what the big thing with man
spreading was a big thing and then
what about there was some pushback what
about these women who put their purses
taken under the seat you're taking up
two seats like this what about these
persons aha same [ __ ] you just want your
space woman spreading women's
purse spread [ __ ] bread
um the worst
that's one that's one i've had at
edinboro i had like a pack show and it
was as many people as you could oversold
it and people were like putting their
[ __ ] down it was like hey we have no
room like
we have no room someone's going to sit
in this room and watch yes move your
[ __ ] thing i know and they always go
ugh like oh oh you're you're the good
guy here i'm the bad guy it's the people
who show up early enough before it gets
packed were you thinking like oh cool i
have my space like dude more people are
coming mm-hmm yeah that's a good pet
peeve
all right so that was one i would just
who the guy i know who's who he is but i
would just move the bag and put it on
the floor and sit down i'm like i'm
sitting here wow there's three chairs in
this [ __ ] i played a club once
and
i'm not gonna trash a club because i
love the club but through the guy who's
like my dog is in there
there'd be a dog a giant dog spread all
over the couch i'd be like the green
room yeah
i don't know
do i sit on the dog
i'll sit on the floor i'll sit on the
floor and curl up yeah at your feet
because i'm a dog yeah put some
newspaper down and i'll lay on the floor
that the owner of the dog needs to step
in there and go hey sorry about uh roxy
was a cute dog but yeah we need it we
need to put in space well the other
feeder's cute too all right i didn't
want to put it i love these i put him on
some newspapers do the same thing where
they're like sorry my kid's screaming
it's like yeah get it out of here you're
having dinner
this is
my wreck have more peeves it's venting
it's yeah it it gets out some of that
[ __ ] anger you're [ __ ] you're like
you're venting about [ __ ] and you
feel better yeah have you had any peeves
that the rest the other two of you guys
go
of course yeah occasionally we both push
back on each other occasionally but for
the most part we're both
that that's the most new york [ __ ] is
just complaining and being like yeah
here's why but then also being like life
is good here's why yes life is good life
is good but it's fun to do this so i
have a bunch of text threads with my
comedian friends we all do
um and you [ __ ] on other comedian
friends
and the reason you do this big jay told
me the reason you do this is so then
let's just say we're [ __ ] on norman
for oh where's plaid so much [ __ ]
moving the plaid so much there's an
innocuous example flannel boy yeah
why's you always be in that flannel boys
group and then when you see him you got
it off your chest you're like hey mark
how you doing
instead
you just got to get it off your chest
yeah yeah that's so true
so true this is what we're calling this
episode the boulevardier flannel boys
yeah do you guys have a house drink at
your house
oh yeah my go-to i do mine is the
godfather the patron what is it again
it's it's amaretto a pd whiskey which we
which we learned together yeah the peter
is the better is because it offsets the
sweetness i love pd you can't have a
smoothie and like
so that's my house drink if somebody's
coming in you know if if i'm coming home
or if my boyfriend's coming with a
[ __ ] some [ __ ] third boy that he
doesn't [ __ ] know you know then it's
like then it's like hey guys how you
doing
two godfathers you start with hey what's
your drink at home mark i go i'm i'm
like you but you guys are mixing more i
just go straight uh lagerville in on the
rocks yeah art bag on the rocks or
tequila on the rocks
underrated oh pd when i when i would do
the when i did uh those amy schumer gigs
her brother loves our best yeah that was
in the room that's where i got into it
oh no you got like a book dude every
barbecue i had by the way july 4th you
both invited um uh view of this uh
[ __ ] fireworks um yep uh every
barbecue i had norm was like i just
brought half a bottle of lagerbull like
what's this half a bottle you know what
that's better than a full bottle of
motion
and then we have the rest exactly that's
better than most full bottles yeah
that's a good gesture yeah i'm a big fan
at home it's usually if i have a friend
over it's usually uh either manhattan
negroni or a martini and
occasionally i will just do straight
whiskey but it's usually some sort of
mixed cocktail cocktail feels like when
you have a friend over it feels like you
put more effort in that's a friend over
for sure i mean if i'm drinking alone i
guess i could do a whiskey but if i have
a friend let me mix you i'm gonna
[ __ ] my friend john weisberg lives in
my neighborhood yeah he comes over i'm
like i'm gonna make you a [ __ ]
martini with some blue cheese olives at
the moment
because that's [ __ ] that no one's
ever not been like oh hell yeah yeah
yeah you just hand someone a a cocktail
they don't go oh i was hoping for
something else they just go thank you
that's a good host yeah
yeah
what's your dream
liquor dream i'll tell you mine so you
can get it started my dream is i can't
do it in new york none of space have a
globe ah
open up
i mean there's something very special i
can have it in the studio room i could
have in the studio what do you call it
like a rolling uh liquor tray i don't
know the bar cart bar cart there's
something so a cloudy cool you have one
spark
i bought one when i moved into my new
place i bought one i'm gonna when i move
i'm gonna get one and then you're like
what do you want yeah it's like well i
have each of the mixers yeah you have
one bottle of coca-cola one bottle of
sprite and then all the
some whiskey some vodka tequila vermouth
right yeah all that [ __ ]
uh when they serve a bloody mary in that
carafe you're like yes yes oh i love you
that's exactly what i want that's my
dream give me a shot of it open if you
can find it
can we get wow
peters i want that for the new studio
yeah can we do it three seven it's on
sale 100 off what is it my father was
wearing he used to beat me with a globe
i hate traveling it's probably because
my dad used to beat me with the globe
yeah
uh are you in your own studio he's
buying a new studio so we're moving like
an average this is [ __ ] homo max and
he owns the place wow really we love you
matt and we're moving gotham studios
soon so we're not gonna be here that
much longer but we are taking the
patrick ewing cutout with us i know
you're all wondering taking it all with
us he's got movers thank god and uh
we're gonna yeah send all this [ __ ] to a
block away wow that's awesome i'm pumped
it's going to be great uh i love i do
love the globe dude i like the gloves
yeah that's a nice touch for a corner
like right in here or like yeah i don't
know just
it looks cool closed we have two seats
and we've also never had double guests
and we might have to start doing double
guess every once in a while let's do it
i mean i've seen double but yeah
well uh here's my other peeve yeah
another quick
second and this might be a new york
thing
only but i got one the the walking down
the big sidewalk every now and then
you're on a big sidewalk it's wide and
you get the family that's doing the full
build that wall build the wall i hate to
build a wall because they're always
going two miles an hour they're looking
up at this
staring
now you're walking in traffic you're
risking getting hit by a [ __ ]
disgruntled driver yeah just because
these people can't spread it out i'm
doing red rover out here yep yep my
another peeve is that with someone
walking too close behind you
just pass especially with us because
pass pass
pass here's another thing about the
mexicans oh hey
yeah exactly they're on you and they all
got phones now they could record you
there was me and uh me and joe list a
popular comedian from new york uh new
york
and mark norman another guy with a pop
pop cuss about uh drinking uh we were
all walking we saw ghosts one of the
worst movies of all time
yeah mara
you were just like a regular yeah very
pretty oh it's terrible everyone's so
bad so bad eating ice cream some lady
behind us is trying to pass us we're
eating ice cream we're literally
strolling yeah and she goes
oh yeah i forgot about it really just
ripped into her like oh yeah this lady's
got busy to get a heart attack she can't
[ __ ] wait two seconds
she's past the wrong people we just
start ripping into her oh i forgot about
that we saw a bad movie we got ice cream
we got friends yeah we were ready to go
oh that movie sucks sucked dude i wanted
to like the reviews are all like wow i
hate when that happens hey critics step
it up
i'm sick of these 95 rotten tomatoes
movies with 40 audience scores i'll tell
you something i was i was like what
you're supposed to like instead of what
you should i was i was i was talking
about that difference that's a [ __ ]
chappelle
i was i was talking to someone the other
day i said oh you know what's a pretty
funny movie is a grandma's boy i said
the funny movie i look it up
percent on runtime oh yeah guess what
the audience score is eighty-seven
eighty-five
that's a fuck-up
how about this freddy got fingered uh i
love freddy got fingers panda is one of
the worst movies of all time saw the
scene where he's having a deep
discussion with his father torn yeah
about who's one of the funniest human
beings ever honey
56 wow that's a big jump big jump but
still still bad he's having a talk with
his dad a really meaningful car and then
he's like
i'm going to make it just go make it son
i'm gonna make it that yeah
56 versus 11. if it's a if it's a 45
plus point difference that's massive
also these are parents going on there
and going hey my son watched this it was
a little much no kidding kids are
watching and going to play
in the movie theater with two of my
friends we were the only three people in
the movie theater no damn hey can i tell
you i was in the worst rated film of all
time
catwoman
no
that's funny
directed we did more amazing races stuff
because he wanted to it was par it was
inappropriate comedy say vince scully
then shlomi
shamwow guy
was like hey do you want to do more
razor stuff no you just got his tongue
bit off by a hooker
and i was like sure we could do it how
much of his tongue is he missing a
quarter damn can he still do the pod
gonna be a guest he should be a guest
all right did he wipe it off
hey and charlie sheen the offer is still
out there we want you on the pod we're
big fans charlie have a drink with us
oh we will either have beer jew or i'll
[ __ ] make i'm a decent bartender we
could make some tiger blood baby charlie
sheet yeah do coke yeah if he wants to
do coke you do coke mark's never done it
you've ever done it well charlie sheen i
would do it
i i'm not doing it that's a snoop dog
that's the snoop dogg of a blind yes
yeah he's a snoop dogg coconuts you got
real ones all right so what were your
story
what was it tom green
freddie got fingered well maybe that was
the end of it it was just the worst
rated movie of all time inappropriate
comedy tom green should come on here man
i love thomas oh he's a sweet guy i love
that inappropriate 2013. oh you're in
this rating look at look i was with hey
oscar award winner adrian brodie and me
we're in a film wow
that has ranged adrian brodie and rob
schneider seven out of ten
zero percent well done
well audience scored 22 i'm pretty close
to the critics zero
man
that's impressive horrible watch i will
not watch again it actually revise
against watching that's a badge of honor
all right we gotta wrap this up
we've been in here
always taping a special at screwball no
not at scarborough they would not have
me back
the roulette intermedium where a great
comic named sam marielle once taped a
special which is so did christa
stephanos so gary goldman a lot a lot of
good specials gary taped the great
depression chris tape size 38 waist
there samuel uh taste the positive
influence uh ari was right here at that
that night
you were there
definitely dude i've seen this show i
haven't seen in a while because it's
been the pandemic but it's called jew
it's called jew it's all about you
growing up as a jew yeah and what
judaism is and stuff like that but
honestly it's just a club funny special
it's a lot of fun though and it's and
it's a very unique story and you really
should go see this roulette what's the
date uh june 11th and 12th saturday and
sunday there it is beautiful i am um
this is my last adventure in brooklyn
what great venue great venue in brooklyn
yeah and borum hills yeah when you say
brooklyn it's like that could mean
anything i know
by atlantic avenue it's right by the
barclays center it's like two blocks in
the barclays center it's like right in
the heart of it you're you're gonna be
fine it's a great kevin durant will be
there so we'll kyrie irving i've seen
they're out of the playoffs i've seen
nuggets of this special throughout you
know at the cellar at the stand at new
york whatever it is the chicken the
swing in the neck
it was like
same thing with the stories where i'm
like this has to for myself this has to
be club funny for sure so like when i
was doing the stories in l.a i'm like i
have to be able to follow bobby lee with
this stuff sure and what i say here is
like these bits have to be able to
follow mark normand yeah if they can't
follow mark normand then it's like then
it's not good enough for sure so it's
like i forget the theme it's gotta just
blend in in a show where you don't
notice it look that guy was funny too
that's good 15 minutes
to do your stories at a comedy club as
well yes because these one-person shows
can get a little indulgent and slower
with you no matter what i saw bigly
going after me at the saddle last night
i'm like i think it's cool that bigly
does seller spots yeah and and he's
doing one-man show stuff too i think
right can you sway them into your point
of view when they're like i want jokes
like i will give you jokes it will be
also something else it's a different
thing and it's it is a harder thing to
do in a club yeah but you can do it yeah
you just have to do it it is you're
right it is harder to do in a 15-minute
set in particular yeah so good on you
for doing it there so i'm taping it june
11th and 12th this is my last day
drinking i'm going to keep going hard
today i want to look good for it so
you're going to look great man thank you
and
just change your face yeah adriana will
open for me on sunday good luck she's
doing denver on the saturday oh i love
it any other road gigs are you coming up
yeah i got jacksonville with uh adrian
uh caitlyn paluffo and louisville and uh
um good that's awesome
it'll be done but like ken city with uh
devito
nice i'm doing a residency all the jew
hour in uh in austin the memorial day
week
i don't know man
all right chicago the day after mark
norman june 18th oh in minneapolis the
day before mark norman are we
flip-flopping there at the pantages yeah
yeah are we flip-flopping i guess so
a lot of crossover come see both of us
come see both of them why not do two
types of comedy
and some [ __ ] we'll mix it up and tampa
have we got in the third show i think so
great they're both sold out yeah
yeah that's going to be a
wild wild night wild weekend be a part
of it say hello be a part of it it's
going to be great have you guys started
taking santa for granted yet or not no i
love it i love it
no i'm very great i mean after the
pandemic i think it really
comes out we got east providence uh
rhode island you're taking your special
the same week and i am morel but it's in
a different city in chicago and new york
can't wait
we're gonna have a lot of fun
are you taping three nights yeah you're
taping three nights three nights why not
smart what one two two
or two two two two wow good for you
cleveland houston west palm dania beach
buffalo all that [ __ ] you're gonna san
jose you're gonna see me soon so i'm
adding dates i forget to put them on my
site but the lot's coming that first
drink after the
second show the third night
oh i'm gonna be [ __ ] lit up okay let
me give you a suggestion please cause
i'm doing this i love my favorite scotch
is this uh cow lily
oh yeah
oh yeah before oh yeah we had it yeah
it's a 10 i think
i bought an 18
year 18 year to have after my special
where it was like i'd order from inc
from scotland it was like 250 bucks and
i'm like i'm gonna ha exactly i'm gonna
have this as a reward for get yourself a
[ __ ] fine liquor i'm gonna have with
you and your friends and whoever's there
exactly robert kelly brought a box of
cigars for joel's wedding and he goes
doesn't matter if you take two puffs
have a [ __ ] nice cigar that's a good
call wow i love it love bobby wait when
is your spoon bobby june 11th and 12th
in in new york new york brooklyn new
york ah damn i want to be there
sunday is the second day i'll be there
okay yeah i'm gonna try if i'm back i'm
gonna definitely come to that nice i'd
love to have you guys i'll tell you this
we all want to um
becky own special oh yeah cause we were
there me sam shane big jay uh uh uh
justin gillis so look out for the look
out for mike
one of all of our friends
it was just like a bunch of comics
and nate had his own personal bus out
front he goes go on their drink and it
was just such a fun hangout and we got
done with the first show we all [ __ ]
you know it was just like
it was like when you got passed yeah it
was like that was like where'd it go we
did it i love him man vic is yeah so it
was just like killer me and shane went
in there tried to like not get too drunk
to like heckle yeah for the second show
but it was just like it's a fun friendly
[ __ ] up your friend's night yeah
whatever michelle's special skirball it
was like i like when everybody's there
they didn't you know zany's in nashville
um like becky owen one of my favorite
jokes of all time where he goes i
sounded to be a private detective online
and they just took my money and i
thought either i just got ripped off
this is my first case
brilliant great mike vecchio he's a good
joke he had a great joke where i'm gonna
butcher this i've been drinking but he
goes uh i went to a vending machine to
buy condoms and they they got stuck so i
started shaking the machine he's like
maybe i shouldn't have a kid
and he says it better he has another one
too where he goes you know i saw a
vending machine for condoms and aspirin
now she's got no mist no excuse
no headache no excuse right yeah great
jokes
i'm in huntsville alabama staying up
live minneapolis uh pantages come see me
not re chicago at the vic cleveland ohio
with the agora
some some bert dates whatever especially
the agora in in cleveland it's selling
horribly making the move well it's so
funny to see mark normand at
a chappelle chappelle movie in in uh in
uh my square garden he didn't see it he
came afterwards yeah
you can cut any of this out you want but
uh-oh but uh we're there somebody goes
hey mark what'd you think of the the
movie he didn't see the movie he was
just he just came with che afterwards
che was like hey we're going literally
after party you want to come he's like
oh sure he goes mark what'd you think
the movie goes a little self-serving but
a little self-indulgent but overall good
i think i was like yeah you're not wrong
and then the guy left and i was like you
didn't see it though right he goes i'm
just guessing
but anyway the point is mark norman's
making the jump now the same with
samurai
it's crazy to see you make the guys it's
like it's not that i don't believe it
but the same sebastian it's like i know
you from the guy who worked at the show
sure so it's like it's so [ __ ] epic
to see the jump of like it's real top
i remember opening for jim jeffries in
2011 and uh
jim sold out every show at caroline's
and he goes well see this place in the
way back down
that's every that sums it all up right
there houston improv comedy club red
bank new jersey lol in san antonio and
uh
all kinds of fun stuff mark norman
comedy i love you keep listening we
might be drunk drunkpod.com
patreon.com we might be drunk pod great
guest
we sell these glasses on the website we
might be drunk pod.com gotham studios we
love you matt yes uh ari go to that
special if you're in new york it's going
to be awesome it's going to be so cool
don't [ __ ] up go to that special great
episode yes blew by we did what two
hours man
easy now it's normal
not two hours
i love these ones where we all got some
chemistry of like real people i know
chill and drink and talk and relax and
be ourselves but that's gonna be a great
special even if you're not jewish go see
it no seriously
no matter what it's gonna be fun so
each and skeptic tanks
skeptic tank check out the pod and uh
get on the patreon get a shirt get a
glass get a drink get a get a get a life
bombed already on two drinks
they were huge i made huge drinks make
another
[Music]
and i get down in the same way
up on the roof like a cob coming and
naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new
orleans this woman doesn't look like i
remember her and i get down in the same
way
we might
be
true
[Music]
you